we're speaking today with Eric burn-off
s'en a professor here at the MIT Sloan
School of Management the director of the
MIT initiative on the digital economy
and co-author of a best-selling book the
second Machine Age a book that really
has gotten the conversation going about
how important today's digital economy is
the technologies that are coming along
are gonna have an enormous effect on the
future of work so Eric thank you for
joining us it's a real pleasure
good let's get started why don't you
tell us why you think the current
technological wave of innovation is as
important as the first Industrial
Revolution with the steam engine and all
the things that went with it well you
know technologies make a huge difference
in the living stance of people for
centuries living standards were
essentially stagnant until James Watt
and others developed a better steam
engine and that ignited the Industrial
Revolution and ever since then living
students have been growing about 2% per
year which adds up to a lot with with
those technologies really did was they
augmented and automated a lot of muscle
power from humans and animals to
machines what we're seeing now is that
machines are beginning to be able to do
the same thing for our brains in our
minds we have computers and software and
big data that are learning how to help
us make decisions how to extend our
mental capacity and that's at least a
profile as profound a difference as what
the steam engine and later the internal
combustion engine and other technologies
did for our muscles
well that's it's very clear that
technological changes like this are very
good for the economy but they also
affect work tell us a little bit about
how technologies affect work in what
ways and positive ways and negative ways
then we can go on from there sure well
the big headline is the first one you
mentioned that the pie is getting bigger
and so let's we got to keep sight of
that that basically these are
technologies that create more abundance
more wealth and there's more wealth now
than there ever has been in history and
global poverty is going down so that's
the good news but the reality is that
there's no economic law that says that
everyone's going to benefit evenly from
this
it's possible for some people to be made
worse off in fact there's no economic
reason that you couldn't have a majority
of people to be made worse off even as
other people get much much better
through most of history there was a
rising tide that lifted most boats
almost all boats but in the past 20
years or so there's been what we call a
decoupling where productivity has
continued to grow GDP per capita has
continued to grow but the median income
the person the 50th percentile knows
below it have seen their incomes
stagnate or even fall and that reflects
the fact that these technologies don't
affect everybody evenly so let's play
this out how do you see these
technologies affecting work in the
future
well the technologies continue to
advance and they continue to affect
different kinds of jobs but what really
matters is how we go about using them
what we've seen so far is that many of
the technologies have been used to
automate a lot of routine information
processing work things like you know
bank tellers bookkeepers a lot of middle
managers in fact about 60% of Americans
primarily do information processing work
so it's a big category and machines are
very good at automating a lot of you
sort of especially the more repetitive
routine information processing tasks it
turns out that the people who do those
jobs are typically in the middle of the
income distribution and what they've
seen is that as machines get better at
those tasks there's less demand for
humans to do the identical tasks or if
they do have to still have jobs they
have to compete with machines that are
doing it more and more cheaply and that
has pushed down wages it's led to fewer
job opportunities in those categories at
the same time there's been growth in job
opportunities at the other ends of the
spectrum what David autor and other
people called polarization job
polarization at the high end you get
creative people or entrepreneurs are
making in some cases more money than
ever before it's probably the best time
in history if you have some kind of
special talent that can be replicated
digitally you might end up being a
billionaire on the other hand the other
end of the spectrum is also seeing some
growth and those are jobs that require a
lot of dexterity or physical tasks or
interpersonal skills things that
machines aren't very good at
the thing is often those jobs don't pay
very well and just to be specific those
are the kinds of jobs like like a waiter
or a gardener or janitor or those kinds
of tasks so what is your advice than two
workers facing this world of changing
technology what should they do in order
to be able to prosper in this this world
well what you'd like to try to do is
strengthen those areas where humans have
an advantage over machines you don't
really want to be competing against
machines ideally you'd like to do things
where machines can leverage your talents
data scientists are more in demand than
ever before because machines have
created an abundance of data but they
can't analyze it they can't even ask the
right questions themselves you need
humans to do that and so if you have
those kinds of skills you're more
valuable than ever and in Silicon Valley
and now companies throughout the country
in the world are greatly demanding those
kinds of workers so there's a set of
categories around that I mentioned
earlier if you have some kind of special
talents or creativity machines aren't
very creative people who can sing well
or who can invent new businesses as
entrepreneurs many kinds of scientists
artists you're right
great if you're great writer write books
those are things that are probably more
valuable now than before another big
category that's gotten to be more
valuable as these as I'm touched on
earlier some of these interpersonal
skills nurturing and caring I think
don't think it would have been very
motivating if at the halftime of the
football games last weekend you know the
coach had been a robot coach you know
you need a human to do that and that
means that you know leadership teamwork
those kinds of things we still connect
with other people a lot better and we
will for some time and I think all those
skills from the creative ones to the
interpersonal the teamwork the nurturing
skills they can all be developed and I
would encourage people to work harder at
developing those kinds of skills become
a better salesperson negotiator
nurturing caring for people
nursing those are all things that I
expect to grow even as machines take
care of more and more of the routine
repetitive kinds of it so that's great
advice too
the workforce let's talk a bit about the
people who are designing these
technologies how can we encourage more
technological design that complements
work that utilizes these skills that
thinks about ways to enhance them or to
to work with them to drive productivity
and economic performance well glad you
asked that question because most people
don't even get as far as asking that
question I think there's a widespread
assumption out there that technology
just happens and there's nothing you can
do to shape the path of it the reality
is that you can encourage people to have
technologies that create more inclusive
innovation that helps people more
broadly or that that mostly focuses on
substituting for people for that matter
and we as a society and as individuals
can shape the direction of technology to
to quite a significant extent one of the
things we can do is change around our
tax policy and our government policies
one of the oldest rules of economics is
if you want less of something you tax it
if you want more of something you
subsidize it right now ironically we are
taxing work if two entrepreneurs come up
with a billion dollar idea and one of
them involves employing lots of people
and one of them doesn't our current tax
system will put more taxes on the one
that employs more people and that's
probably not what we want to do
conversely we don't tax pollution carbon
congestion things that we'd like to see
less of so we could rejigger the tax
system to have less of the things that
tax tax of things that we don't want
more and it will have less of them and
lower the taxes or even subsidize work
and I think that would guide
entrepreneurs to be more creative about
inventing things that have less
pollution and more widespread labor the
Earned Income Tax Credit is a good
example but too small could be expanded
of that another kind of thing we do is
just recognize reward and motivate
people one of the things that I've
learned over the past few years is how
is how much people can be motivated by
having a prize and a goal in front of
them I've been watching the DARPA
Robotics Challenge the DARPA Grand
Challenge that led to the driverless car
and I see my colleagues and engine
grad students professors working nights
and weekends to solve this challenge
that have been put in front of them and
and many times they do come around to
making huge strides in that why don't we
try to reward and motivate business
leaders and economists to reinvent the
businesses and economy the same way the
technologists have been reinventing the
technology and in fact here at MIT we're
launching something called the inclusive
innovation competition which is designed
specifically to recognize those business
models that use technology to create
broad shared prosperity we call it
shared prosperity for the the many not
just a few and it's just getting
launched but we think that this is going
to be a good way to recognize and
highlight people who've done that I
think that's a great idea and I hope
that it creates a lot of attention and
that we get lots of people really
thinking along these ways because I
think it's the genius of of people using
technologies to it address important
problems that will help yeah and we can
all we all have choices we can shape the
future in that direction and why we
encourage people who are doing it in a
way that does create this shared
prosperity this final question because
it's obviously on everybody's mind and
that is from time to time in history as
you know better than I people I have
worried that technology is going to
replace work it's going to be the end of
work we're not going to have enough jobs
and that's a that's an issue on people's
mind today how do you think about that
problem given all of the innovation
that's going on and that could come down
the road well down the road I can
certainly imagine technology creating
kind of a Star Trek economy and I don't
think that's necessarily a bad thing
if technology is able to take care of
all of our basic needs for us but the
more immediate issue is not that
technology is going to eliminate all the
jobs but the types of jobs that are
affected the reality is is that
technology has always been destroying
jobs it's always been creating jobs but
most importantly is been changing the
mix and what we're seeing recently as I
touched on earlier is that that mix is
changing in a way that a lot of people
are being made worse off and other
people are being made much
better off and we want to try to shape
the direction of the technology we want
to also give people the skills and
education so they can adapt to the new
kinds of jobs that are available and if
we do that I think we're going to be
able to have that kind of world of
shared prosperity the technology will
march on and we shouldn't try to stop
the technology that's how we get that
bigger pie that that growth that I
mentioned but we can direct it in the
earlier industrial revolutions when the
steam engine other technologies came
along you know we adapted our
institutions we invented mass public
education first in the primary level and
then later at the secondary level we
invented Social Security and a whole
bunch of other policies that helped
smooth that transition to a new kind of
workforce and cushion the people who
otherwise would have been left behind
we're gonna have to reinvent education
again this time we're gonna have to do
our best to shape the technology that is
aligned with our values ultimately it's
not what the technology does to us
technology is a tool it's always been a
tool whether it's a hammer or an
enterprise resource planning system we
have more powerful tools now than we
ever had before and that means we have
more power to shape the future than we
ever did before but it starts with
understanding that we have that power
and aligning our actions with our values
well Eric I think that's a really
important message and one that I'm
delighted that we can deliver in this
class and in other settings where people
can really make a difference so thanks
for joining us today it's a tremendous
pleasure thanks a lot tom